[Applauso]
[Musica]
Scusate stavo accordando il mio
sistema di intelligenza artificiale
intelligenza artificiale questo nome
altisonante si sente spesso oggi ma
dov'è l'intelligenza artificiale che
cos'è l'intelligenza artificiale lo
siete mai chiesti dai proviamoci per
l'alzata in mano così ci conosciamo un
po' Quanti di voi pensano che
l'intelligenza artificiale sia un
concetto un po' lontano per esempio che
magari appartenga ad istituti di ricerca
su per avanzati questi posti
industrializzati sulle mani
bene grazie Quanti di voi invece pensano
che sia molto più vicino magari nella
nostra nel nostro Quotidiano
bene molto bene Giusto per essere sicuri
astenuti
ha alzato molto bene l'intelligenza
artificiale oggi non fa solo parte dei
grandi istituti di ricerca
internazionali di fatto è parte della
nostra quotidianità
se vi dicessi che la maggior parte di
noi in questo momento probabilmente ce
l'ha in tasca
pensate per esempio a quelle App per i
servizi di intrattenimento che basandosi
su delle scelte storiche nostre oppure
di quelle di altri utenti con preferenze
simili alle nostre ci raccomandano la
nuova canzone da ascoltare la nuova
serie TV al nuovo film da guardare
oppure al nuovo prodotto da acquistare
oppure pensate alle applicazioni per la
creazione di contenuti multimediali tipo
quelle che ti permettono di farti una
foto e ci costruiscono delle animazioni
grafiche intorno per esempio quella con
cui ti puoi guardare con un diverso
taglio di capelli diverso colore degli
occhi o quelle che ti fanno la faccia
carota Ecco abbiamo capito che
l'intelligenza artificiale è oggi ce
l'abbiamo in tasca e ci aiuta a fare
cose interessantissime tipo la faccia
carota ma
Che cos'è l'intelligenza artificiale
Allora se dovessimo dare una definizione
potremmo dire che è un sistema
addestrato sulla base di preferenze
scelte storiche per svolgere compiti
specifici in modo autonomo chiaro
Limpido proprio cosa vuol dire sta roba
Aspetta un attimo un sistema addestrato
per svolgere compiti specifici in modo
autonomo sistema è una macchina
addestrato come a destra di una macchina
e visto che tocca a noi farlo come
insegniamo a una macchina quello che
deve fare
più o meno nello stesso modo in cui si
siano le cose dei bambini per esempio ci
sono
prendiamo un bambino appena uscito dallo
scaffale nuovo questo non sapevo più
niente e Dobbiamo insegnare delle cose
In quanti modi possiamo insegnare delle
cose ce ne sono tanti ma tre sono
abbastanza universali Il primo è per
associazione per esempio quando gli
insegniamo i nomi dei colori
indicandoglielo oppure Quando impara a
leggere associa il suono ad ogni lettera
Il secondo è attraverso le regole
mettere sempre via i giochi dopo averli
usati salutare dire grazie prego sempre
chiedere permesso ai genitori prima di
far saltare la casa proprio così insomma
in ultima forse il metodo più potente
gli si insegna attraverso le esperienze
lasciandoli vivere
liberi di andare magari con qualche
Premio di incoraggiamento se fanno
qualcosa di giusto pensate a un percorso
scolastico oppure una passione che viene
coltivata ci saranno degli obiettivi
definiti insieme agli insegnanti o ai
genitori e il bambino avrà dei mezzi
magari dei premi di incoraggiamento però
di fatto poi la strada la fa da solo
ebbene con gli stessi modi possiamo
insegnare qualcosa alle macchine uno dei
tre esempi citati è quello che in gergo
tecnico si chiama apprendimento
supervisionato
per intenderci è quello che abbiamo
definito per associazione Cioè ti faccio
vedere i colori e per ogni colore ti
dico esattamente qual è il suo nome
L'aspetto fondamentale
dell'apprendimento supervisionato è che
non si lasci spazio a dubbi
Cosa vuol dire che se ti faccio vedere
La Palette intera per ognuno di quei
colori ti devo dare un etichetta un nome
e ovviamente che le associazioni fatte
siano corrette se io prendo il bambino
che nel frattempo è uscito dalla scatola
e gli faccio vedere la foto di una
carota e gli dico che quella lì è una
rosa poi il rischio che questo cresca
presentandosi al primo appuntamento
romantico con il mazzo sbagliato
già tanto senso tornando alla nostra app
delle facce a carota Chiunque abbia
progettato un'app simile Deve
necessariamente avere insegnato alla
macchina Come riconoscere i volti
umani nelle immagini
e in che modo l'avrà fatto beh
probabilmente è un apprendimento
supervisionato perché una volta che è il
volto lo riconosci poi ci applichi
l'effetto sopra no
bene però nel dettaglio Nel pratico come
l'avrei istruito Questa è la domanda
Come avrai istruito la macchina allora
per portarvi all'interno della scatola
magica e mostrarvi un pochino più da
vicino come funziona questo processo ho
portato con me un strumento di
avanzatissime innovazione tecnologica la
chitarra di legno
e adesso vorrei che mi accompagnaste nel
processo di
accordarla
focalizzatevi su quali sono i passettini
semplici
Come se doveste scrivere la ricetta su
come si accorda una chitarra allora
passo numero 1
Suono un accordo
tu sei d'accordo
passo numero due
ascolto e confronto il suono emesso
dalla chitarra con il suono che io mi
aspetto cioè quello che io so essere
corretto
Cosa vuol dire far questo confronto è
come si misurassi la differenza lo
scarto L'errore che c'è tra i due errore
perché Perché è come se stessi
quantificando di quanto è sbagliato il
suono che esce rispetto a quello che io
so essere giusto
ora capite perché è fondamentale che
nell'apprendimento supervisionato le
associazioni siano corrette e siano
puntuali una una Perché altrimenti non
avrei il termine di paragone per poter
capire di quanto sto sbagliando comunque
tornando all'accordatura
E dopo che li ho suonati se i due sono
uguali TAC al concerto è pronta
se i due sono diversi Cosa faccio
è giusto il pirulino di quanto non lo so
tiri molli È un processo itativo quindi
riparti dal punto 1 prima o poi la
speranza è la chitarra è che la chitarra
sarà accordata la potrò lasciare lì
qualcun altro potrà passare e tac via al
concerto ora tornando nel nostro esempio
delle facce a carota nel caso della
macchina quello che faremo sarà
preparare tante immagini alcune con i
volti e alcune senza volti immagini di
cui noi sappiamo Qual è la risposta
esatta un po' come per la chitarra
sapevamo quale fosse l'accordo giusto Ok
il suono giusto poi ne prendiamo alcune
e diciamo
adesso gli facciamo un indovinello di
quelle immagini che prendiamo
nascondiamo
la risposta esatta diamo l'immagine in
pasta alla macchina e gli chiediamo di
indovinare
la macchina ci darà una risposta e poi
cosa ci facciamo questa risposta la
confrontiamo misuriamo la differenza
Quella risposta che sapevamo essere
esatta quella che avevamo nascosto in
base a questa differenza ci sarà un
errore l'errore ci darà un numero con
cui sintonizzeremo la macchina di
intelligenza artificiale di quanto è di
quanto sarà sufficiente a bilanciare
l'errore poi lì la matematica ci aiuta
fatto questo percorso cosa facciamo lo
ripetiamo da capo
essendo un processo iterativo la
speranza è che prima o poi la macchina
abbia davvero imparato a riconoscere le
foto con all'interno i volti umani
ora perché vi ho detto tutto questo
perché
potrei darvi una chitarra accordata
malissimo e poi essere accusato di aver
rovinato delle melodie stupende E la
cosa non mi renderebbe felice così come
dall'altro lato potrei darvi una
chitarra col suono più pulito del mondo
e poi vedere qualcuno che la usa per
giocare a tennis
e anche lì non penso che saremo felici
in tanti Il punto è che che sia
intelligenza artificiale o una chitarra
La responsabilità è un po' di tutti Oggi
l'intelligenza artificiale può dare la
voce alle persone affette da mutismo
o addirittura
abbassare di parecchio i rischi di
incidenti stradali con le conseguenze
del caso Grazie alle tecnologie
innovative che abbiamo a disposizione
nelle nostre auto
c'è dell'intelligenza artificiale già in
atto oggi che negli ospedali sei a
individuare i tumori con largo anticipo
e laddove nemmeno L'occhio umano può
arrivare
Tuttavia come tutte le cose affascinanti
che non si comprendono fino in fondo è
normale legittimo e umano nutrire dei
timori
timori che poi il cinema ha provveduto
amplificare facendo l'intelligenza
artificiale protagonista di storie
inquietanti minacce di stupire
Ecco storia vincenti Sicuramente ma
altrettanto un po' inverosimili in
alcuni casi e rischio lì è che se si dà
retta a queste rappresentazioni si perde
di vista il vero rischio e la vera
minaccia di un intelligenza artificiale
addestrata male ed usata anche peggio
quindi che siate programmatori di
intelligenza artificiale o semplici
fruitori di servizi Non fa mica tanta
differenza
Il punto è che credo fermamente che ogni
energia ogni sforzo investito per
educare in merito a questa tecnologia
possa aiutare ad un utilizzo migliore
più consapevole con meno timori e più
curiosità Grazie mille
[Applauso]